today's workshop is about uh proof
complexity of solvers
and the first talk is going to be by
paul beam
paul doesn't really need an introduction
he's
legendary in proof complexity and
complexity theory in general
but uh what i would like to focus on
or as i introduce him is the fact that
this entire area of
uh applying proof complexity to sat
one could argue was initiated by paul
with the seminal results in the early
2000s where he showed
equivalence between cdcl with some
pre-processing and
resolution so without any further delay
uh paul
the online floor is yours thank you uh
thank you vijay
and i think for the uh generous
introduction
so uh i'm gonna talk about a uh
a story that uh connects us
proof complexity and verification and
and
illustrates some of the issues in going
back and forth
between the two so this is about using
resolution and cutting planes for
verification
of non-linear bit vector properties so
let me uh talk about what that
is so in general uh
this is uh involves uh so what is bit
vector verification this could be in
hardware or software i've shown a little
piece of
software in general you have
some code that involves
bit level operations on things like
integer variables
plus arithmetic operations and you have
some specification
uh that also might involve uh some of
those uh
operations so the general way things
work in
uh with bit vector verification
you convert the uh integer variables
into
blocks of bits or 32-bit bit vectors for
example if they're ins
and directly model the into operators
and arithmetic operations and bit level
operations
and then you write a formula over that
theory asserting that the code does not
follow the specification
so uh you send that form formula to the
solver if the solver says that
form was unset the then you found that
the program
uh follows the spec okay so that's the
the basic form their variations
uh in hardware and software a big
challenge
of a bit vector solvers is a non-linear
arithmetic so there's
actually been tremendous success if all
the arithmetic in your
in your code is linear or if your your
target
spec uh is is linear but there have been
major problems with nonlinear arithmetic
and no bit
or solvers even close to working well in
general
at varying verifying hardware
implementations that involve
multiplier circuits or software that
involves
multiplication operations and pretty
much anything else
though uh in parallel with some of the
work that i'm uh
talking about there's actually been
significant recent progress
on verifying multiplier circuits in
isolation and
daniella kaufman uh gave a a great talk
in this
in the beyond sat workshop and i
highly recommend uh looking at the
recording of the talk
uh so exactly how does this challenge
come in
so in general in hardware you directly
model the circuits using boolean logic
and gate variables and software you
model but you won't have these
arithmetic operations in software you're
going to directly
model the operations including
arithmetic in the bit character language
and you will actually apply theories
directly
to simplify or prove via pre-processing
of the various properties so you can use
theories of uninterpreted functions or
arithmetic identities
at that point but often that only gets
you so far
you've simplified some of that
arithmetic away but there
for example still may be a bunch of it
so if you don't have any
uh thing more you can do you what's
called you bit blast the formula
there's a more pedestrian term flat in
it
to convert it uh the arithmetic theory
to a fixed bid with say and typically
for
for practical interest you'd need at
least 32 or 64 bits
and what does that mean so we have these
arithmetic operations
that uh are supposed to do addition
multiplication and so on
uh but you only have boolean variables
now so what you do is you
pick some circuit that evaluates that
property and you
add gate variables and constraints for
that circuit in order to evaluate it
now the entire uh result is
a boolean formula and you send that say
to a sat solver
so you can um so that's the the general
uh approach and here's an example of
of what you might do as your circuit for
example for
addition so if you have a one bit adder
you uh
uh would have a a single uh full adder
circuit outputs the majority
sorry the the carry out is the majority
the the output is the parity
um actually for things later uh
we're going to want to think of this in
terms of a conservation of weight
constraint
so which is an arithmetic uh constraint
though so then the normal thing for
example you're translating the clauses
you translate the majority in parity to
causes
we're also going to look at the case
where we want to translate
uh this uh to the conservation of weight
formula and then you
stick these full adders together to get
for example a ripple carry adder circuit
it doesn't have to be depth optimum or
anything like that
uh what you want is ease of verification
um
for multipliers there are uh even more
options
um here's an example circuit which i'm
going to use as a running example and
it's actually
maybe the the most simple and natural
circuit so you
write out the ordinary bit tableau that
you would do
uh using the uh you know elementary
school
uh method except over bits and then you
get
uh then you add up uh the bits and this
is a nice way
of doing it as you're going along using
the the one bit adder so that's the
array multiplier
uh and i'm going to call that layout of
of the bits from the tableau which is
the elementary school
method and the tableau is a nice way to
to look at what's going on so that's
what you have as a circuit
um for example if you wanted to verify
that a multiplier was commutative um
so you fix some bit within you construct
the
bit blasted sat formula for involving
the gate variables for each of the two
circuits so
it's the same shape circuit we put in
the x and y
inputs in different positions so they're
in some sense different multiplier
circuits
and then we add in uh the constraint
which says that one of the output
corresponding output bits differ so
that's the the natural formula
uh for this uh question that you get
from this bit blasting
and here's what happens if you try to
run it into a sat solver
you can see that we wanted 32 or 64 bits
you get timeout for example with mini
sata you
can get a little better with others but
it's it's just a
convenient example you get a timeout
very few bits
um the formulas aren't actually that big
there are thousands of variables
uh hundreds of thousands actually it
breaks right around a thousand
the and then uh arm and b area observed
that sat solvers cannot solve this for
16 bit vectors which might be the first
sort of
interesting case for any uh multiplier
circuit doesn't matter what one you
stick in and he
he gave them as uh some of these as
challenge problems for
for the sat race for the sat competition
and the the solvers did
were simply unable to do this so
um so i'm going to be discussing
arithmetic identities like this
as indicators of complexity and this is
actually what uh
armin suggested as well if you didn't
have a specification
you'd actually have to use these
identities even to define what you meant
by um correctness of a multiplier you
can use these identities to do that
but in general in the in the um
so in general it turns out for the
linear case they're easy to
uh check um but it's hard to check in
the
the non-linear case commutativity is
just one example it's actually one of
uh there are others uh as well some
can be even worse um and the key point
is
these are indicative of the kinds of
issues that
one is going to uh encounter when you
start
combining these identities which might
get
um pre-processed away uh in your bit
factor solving but you want to combine
it later with some other property
uh so of of your circuit so you've got a
multiplier but you're using bit level
logic as well
i have a question paul sure just to get
to an intuition
so if y in the you know commutativity
identity if y
were a constant like five would be
that's fine that's in that
multiplicative identity up top so
so by linearity if if one of the uh
arguments is a constant
that is something that current solvers
can handle
but they can't handle the the uh things
and typically smallish constants but but
in general they're fine with constants
so things are linear
in uh in that sense uh because they've
got constant coefficients
yeah thanks yeah so we're we're
interested in the general case
you might for example be interested in
software hey let me check the hash
functions in my
uh and i really care what they are in my
cryptographic generator things like that
so
uh there there are lots of instances
where we really want
real multiplication so
another part another question sure
do we know what is the the complexity of
resolution for commutativity
okay that fancy that you should ask that
this is is resolution complexity a
fundamental obstacle you just
anticipated the next slide
and this was actually a conjecture a few
years ago
is that the reasons and it's pretty
obvious you can actually plot it that
they're actually taking extra the
solvers are actually taking exponential
time
to decide this just even communicativity
uh and the reason conjectured was that
resolution proofs
require exponential socks um and there's
there was you know strong feeling about
that
um so um
so this is what actually got me
interested in the question of you know
resolution complexity of these
uh questions that got us interested um
i should say i forgot to at the start
this is joint work with my phd
student uh vincent liu
who graduated last year uh yo devrind
uh of and uh john alphers and jacob
nordstrom
from lund and uh copenhagen i i
i forgot to uh um say that earlier
um so vincent and i started looking at
the problem and so now if you think
about the uh
the question of of um
telling that these two circuits are
different the natural thing is
start checking the bits from uh right to
left seeing
okay they're equal they're equal so far
okay i found
uh an inequality so uh if you're
thinking in sort of dpl framework that's
the right thing if you think of
resolution proofs think of those as the
last steps of the resolution proof
but now we've got these two uh circuits
and we've got an
out uh an output difference um but if
you look at the values
they're sensitive to all the prior bits
um wow i have to be really careful what
i touch
um so in general
if you would look at this and go through
the obvious resolution proof using the
properties the obvious
uh proof that this is unsatisfiable that
it's not
possible to have this combination
is exponential and key thing
that uh vincent realized
is that there's a critical strip
of just the prior login columns that
suffice
for this unsatisfiability in fact we can
complete well
we we already knew we could ignore the
bits to the left
but we can also completely ignore the
bits to the right
and so we get these critical strips
and in these critical strips of of login
bits
notice the input bits are completely
unconstrained
so there they just have they they're
only they only feed in there no values
for those
and this is also unsatisfiable and the
reason
is uh the internal bits in the
strips if you're doing commutativity are
actually the same bits but they're
be muted in different places the
carrying bits may be completely
different
but you know if you had your circuit
there you'd know that they added up to
the same sum
but even without that circuit there the
difference in value is at most n
if you think of the the right hand entry
as being
you know like the ones column and if you
add that
up that's not enough of a sum to create
a difference in the higher order bit
say to have the left one be one and the
right one be
zero and so um we own that's why it's
unsatisfiable
and so now the one other thing we need
is that
each critical strip wow
has a polynomial size regular resolution
uh refutation and this is because this
graph has log n
path width in fact it's a a simpler
graph than general uh simpler proof than
general regular resolution
it's ordered there's a fixed order in
which you can do the resolution on every
path
and that's polynomial and that's our
result goes back to
uh dexter in 96 dectare 96 and
and others so the net result
of this is that for all for all of the
multipliers
all the standard multipliers like array
diagonal and booth
uh there are no they're sorry there are
poly size resolution proofs
in fact you can extend this not just to
multiple uh commutativity but any degree
to identity and
uh vince and i had the paper on this and
kav and the
journal version and jsm this year the
last year
um so how big are they
um well they're they're okayish
uh so the proof size for bit with n
is about n to the six where we should
compare with the circuit size about n
squared
um that's potentially on the edge
uh some identities are a bit worse this
is
pretty much the worst of the ones
because of the uh
the computations back and forth
um but sometimes we know you know this
was just a theory result
often we find there's other proofs that
the solvers see that
you know maybe we uh we don't so
uh the question is how now that we've
got polynomial size how does this work
for practical
cdcl solving well we do the strips
version i put it
side by side with the full version and
we get some improvement
but we don't really get
much further um
so okay so are we we worked a while
can we give some hand-holding can we
we make some tweaks to these uh
solvers and we tried a number of them
but mini set was just the simplest for
us
uh to work with which is why i'm
reporting those
um it doesn't define uh these proofs
even given the division into strips
they're uh they're at least a factor of
n
bigger they they do seem to have
polynomial
dependence but but it's horrible and the
polynomial crossover point
is actually um uh
not not much different from from the
exponential
and with extreme hand-holding force-fed
order lots of other things
we can't get closer empirically than a
factor of square would event of the best
and of the six seems too large in any
case we want to target much bigger
values than this
so um the only solution was
to go to a stronger proof system and
here's all a number of proof systems
we've
heard about in their relationships
we're going to focus just on three
um so cutting planes and polynomial
calculus in addition to
uh resolution and the polynomial
calculus story
started with in parallel with our work
so reminding you polynomial calculus you
have you convert each line
into a polynomial equation uh you have
rules on derivation if you've got
something at zero their sum
is zero and their product is zero and
you use properties of boolean variables
to say
that the square is equal to the value of
the variable
um polynomial calculus uh has uh
implemented you know models the steps of
the grubhner basis reduction
uh algorithms so uh that's
in in in part its origins
and we know uh that polynomial calculus
is stronger than resolution
so we'd like it to be the case that
means
the grebner basis reduction would be
more efficient than sat
up to you know usual implementation
factors well
um no first of all on most algebraic uh
problems and there are a number of
issues with this one of which is that
grubhner basis reduction algorithms
destroy the
the twin variables or dual variables
that one actually needs
uh for the polynomial calculus
sufficient simulation of resolution
and the other is just general um
overheads of course
um and it's just not particularly well
tailored for things involving clauses
and things
and such however for certain algebraic
problems
uh you can uh like these multipliers in
isolation it works extremely well
so kaufman at all that were able to
verify 1024-bit integer multipliers
using uh grovner basis reduction uh
techniques and in fact
their proof in polynomial calculus
uh actually is order n squared which is
optimal it's the size
of the instance
and it's at the word level and notice
the coefficients here required are
relatively large so they're
they're they're a big uh coefficient and
you can actually generalize this to any
word level ring identity
um and not just degree two
now this is great and this was
uh kind of the uh the state of the art
uh before we started uh work on on the
next project with
with the uh team at london copenhagen
and one thing we realize is that these
uh polymer calculus proofs are treating
the numbers themselves as individual
units they're at the word level
if you actually wanted to integrate this
with logic you'd need those values at
the bit level
and it turns out if you just if you just
have the statement that two words are
equal here i'm showing
them as x y and y x but they're just add
two abstract words and you want to know
we want to derive from that that a given
pair of bits is equal even if you had
twin variables
the proof size to derive that is
exponential
in the the number of bits of the word
so integration of the polynomial
calculus
with the bit level uh things is
uh is itself a
tricky process so that uh
is one of the things we're actually
already starting to look at
cutting plants proof um and so in
cutting planes
um you have linear inequalities where
the coefficients are integers
and in general they can be arbitrary of
integer variables x i but we're going to
think about them just for boolean
variables
um so we have non-negative linear
integer combination so if l1 and l2 are
non-negative so
is there non-negative linear in a
integer combination
and also division if we have a linear
inequality where the left side has a
common factor
we can divide it out so the left side uh
has integral values and now the right
hand side
uh is a fraction if it uh that could be
rounded up
because we know the left hand side is an
integer so that's
uh cutting planes and if we're going to
use cutting planes we're going to need
something that
implements them and the uh
this the best pseudo boolean solvers
use features of cutting planes proofs
some do not but the very uh best ones do
and we'll see that that's going to be
absolutely essential for
the success of using that um
so what about this issue that was a
problem uh for bit vector solvers well
if we already had the word level
equality for example and it's not
required that it be a word level
equality
you you have these uh constraints
then cutting planes can in fact derive
all in
bit inequalities all of them at once in
order n
steps and this is with rounding sat a
particular pseudo boolean solver one of
the
best current solvers um and we can do it
in
fractions of a second for uh numbers
that are plenty
uh uh plenty big enough uh in contrast
this is not true for every
pseudo-boolean solver so
saffroj has multiple uh instances
including one that is cutting plane
space but if you use the resolution
version of them
um if it uh it fails and
naps also uh fails on very small bit
widths i mean you'll see that's that's
28 just to extract these
uh bit level bid equalities
uh so that's great assuming we can get
the word level
equalities uh correct uh
and in fact we can get small cutting
plans proof so the word level equalities
um for not all ring identities but a
large class that we call
too colorable we don't know you can't
for others but uh
these are the ones we were able to do
and examples include commutativity
distributivity
and others like that um and of course
because of the previous results
their n-squared length cutting planes
proof for bit-level
uh ring identities which is the first
one that can do identities at the
the bit level and so um
so that's uh that's very nice i want to
give you a basic idea
of how this works um
we can do because rally recall these are
non-linear properties but we're using a
proof system that only deals with linear
constraints so the general idea is we
can use
only a little non-linear error linearity
of a time
at a time we actually found it
convenient to describe these in terms of
a
slight extension of cutting planes
proofs where we allow
a small amount of non-linearity
so we've got k terms where each of
degree d or less
and each term well it can actually have
a one linear component and then just
multiplied by a monomial or it could
just be a monomial itself
and uh you just have the constraints on
the the combination rules is that it
retains this property
so um so how do you simulate it well
here's a bit of intuition so here's the
theorem about how you can simulate it
um so you can expand the number of of
lines a little bit you can simulate this
little bit of non-linearity
sort of a geometric intuition if we had
some degree two
uh curve that was splitting out some
points we would just replace it by two
lines
uh you can you can think about the the
general form
that simulation isn't um you know
there's some tricks to it but uh you
should be
it's an intuitively not uh on uh
not a uh difficult one but there are
some nasty technical
difficulties uh if you're not careful
um so we get the two colorable
identities by showing that we can
uh get n squared length cutting planes
proofs where
they're in this little bit of
nonlinearity where k and d are constant
d
is two and k is i don't know three or
four
so with this constant overhead
simulation we get an n squared type
size proof in standard cutting planes
um so um
what about finding these cutting plants
proofs by a pseudo boolean solvers
and the two solvers that we worked with
are sad for j in its full cutting plans
mode and rounding set
which i uh mentioned earlier and these
have
two very complementary approaches to
um how they derive and learn uh new
inequalities
um sat4j is saturation based
which um uh you should check uh
jacob's boot camp talk for the details
but basically involves
thresholding uh coefficients uh by the
right hand side
and it turns out these are fast for
proving the word level equalities
rounding set is division based and fat
fast at extracting bit level equalities
um well okay so what so there is a
question
uh paul by meanwhile
so mina mahajan asked what are the
non-linear
kd terms inter uh interpreted in terms
of the
ky partial product well you've got to do
a very basic thing
i mean there's a very basic one that's
uh that's three
uh easy inequalities that i'll mention
for um the case of
um just the tableau i've actually got
that on a later slide
um in general for example for
distributivity there's a little bit as
kind of at the edge so they're just a
few things that are
representing partial products as you
would sweep through left to right
uh comparing uh the undistributed and
distributed version
so i i don't have i can't write them
down but
but they're but they're very short so
does that answer the question
yes that's okay thanks thanks um
yeah so uh so these so what we have to
do
is we take a combination of these two
which nicely work on the same
representation
uh we're able to do 256 a bit
commutativity at the bit level
we can do multiplier equivalence
checking we can check against the spec
and things like that
it does require that value based
uh uh version of one bit adders
rather than the causal representation so
that's essential
if you're going to use pseudo boolean
solvers you cannot
reduce things to clauses first otherwise
at the moment
they they even though cutting planes
proofs can handle it
pseudo boolean solvers at the moment if
you give them causes
will behave like slow versions of cdcl
solvents so
you it's absolutely essential that you
do this but that's an
obvious thing that any uh system that's
going to use them in the context of bit
voucher solving
is going to do it's going to know to
hand off
his uh one bit adders uh rather than
uh you know in in this nicer form um
here are some running times uh so
they're in in the matter of not too many
seconds
at the moment we're limited they can't
handle the more complicated
identities such as uh distributivity
and we don't have a
single solver with a single uh heuristic
decision thing
that will combine these two methods to
do this we have to
combine them in uh in a more
uh abstract uh uh way rather than sort
of
at the low level be really nice to be
able to combine it at the no level
and know a low level and know when to
use saturation-based
or division-based reasoning
so um one of the things that we can also
see is there's another approach to bit
blasting so if you
actually want to use uh uh
these for uh in bit factor solving
we think there's an even better way to
use uh
cutting plane solvers and one thing by
the way for all of these solvers
um uh i guess i'll i'll skip it but for
all of these solvers 256 bits that means
that we've got to
be able to represent in our solver
things like 2 to the 256
and or 2 to the 511 something like that
or 510.
so it's important that these solvers be
able to use
large coefficients in uh
the original version of rounding set
that we began with we only had
uh restricted a bit widths
later it's been exp it was expanded to
the the many more bits and so some of
our results
are with uh bit level restricted but
it's not just
two to boolean solvent but pseudo
boolean solving with large
uh coefficients and so i didn't mention
earlier when i was doing the
uh there was a failure of one of the
solvers
on uh the the bid extraction and that
was because the coefficients
weren't uh it couldn't handle large
coefficients anyway sorry
back to the uh this message of uh
approach to bit blasting
so we need this uh um equation
and this is two inequalities it's right
written as an equation but it's really
two inequalities and cutting plans
instead of what would be 14 clauses but
the key is actually
how we can do the inference as a result
okay so um we can do something more
we could actually represent that
addition
without the circuit so we don't need to
fully bit blast
to a circuit we can represent it
directly and
implicitly that's a that's a reasonable
way
that would be nice uh to use even the
the polymer calculus uh results but
unfortunately
that's not quite enough uh because we
can't
of the bid extraction problem but we can
do more we can represent
multiplication without a circuit so we
just put in the n squared tableau
constraints
for those uh for those uh tableau
products and we just write in a sum
constraint for that
tableau and bypass all the one bit
adders and just
put in uh the specification of a full
adder
now the tableau constraints themselves
are are
are not um pseudo boolean but
um i i we can uh
represent them by these three equalities
this is like the simplest case of uh of
a small amount of non-linearity being
simulated
uh by uh pseudo boolean constraints
so how does this work so this is using
this
um we can beat bit vector solvers
without
any other handholding without combining
um
with this algebraic representation of
multiplication
so we we did a simple example that uh
just as a test to mix multiplication and
bitwise
operation so imagine you have a large
constant k you want to say k times e
is at least some input x
anded bitwise with with k and multiplied
by z so that's a new integer
we multiply uh by z clearly the
coefficient is smaller so that should be
true
and rounding set is able to do it now we
we did these experiments with the
earlier version of of rounding set so
there's a
limited bit width but as you can see um
boolector uh times out even at uh
uh 28 bits and it's really focused on
the bit vector case and z3 which is more
general
so a bit slower also uh times out
on these so um we think that this
approach of combining these two sorts of
solving is really
uh going to be the the uh important
going forward
future directions so um
we we can do better there's much more to
be done in terms of integrating these
types of things
uh use using pre-processing to make
things
uh great for for uh pseudo boolean
solvers
uh do this algebraic blasting can we get
good performance on industrial
industrial benchmarks
that involve multiplication so that's a
an application question
the other side is the fundamental engine
side of this cutting plane
saw uh is powerful but pseudo boolean
solving implements only a small piece of
it
uh we were not able to solve the more
complicated identities
the heuristics and inference rules are
are not well
uh you know are not uniformly integrated
like cdcl everybody builds on everybody
else's ideas and there's sort of a a
great path that's been going forward
um there have been these crucial sad
insolvent uh sad improvements
uh we think this application might be
motivational
um uh for uh at the uh
and so karen i see you have a a question
please
uh i'm gonna wait until you're done i
it's kind of a random question
so i'll wait for you oh okay so uh
finally
uh so this is you know relatively
uh you know uh fresh territory you know
go their pioneers we think this is uh
a great uh place to uh for future work
thanks i'm done go ahead karen um okay
so
something struck me which is these
circuits are very regular
yes is there a place for induction on
these things
like if you can't show your
distributivity holds for
eight bits can you learn something from
that and
i know that these circuits are generated
you know from a you know
by some tool that increases bit width
and so on
so let's assume that that generator is
correct
is there something that you can learn
from a narrow bit width multiplier that
you can then say i can then
uh you know lift it to a 128 or 256.
so it's
really unclear so in general first of
all
this would be a multiplier in the like
we've described things in terms of
multipliers
somewhat in isolation or compared to
each other or compared with a spec
but in this larger combination where you
have
some software that where you are
checking the integration with them
of a multiplier with other things for
example if you wanted to verify things
like aes
where you're doing bit twiddling
operations there is no induction that's
going to
to get you to work so yes in isolation
we have the theories
of that we could use as pre-processing
but we want to avoid that because those
are bypassing those don't help you uh
and and the induction for those does not
work in the context
of uh other other bid operations that's
why we
we don't think about that so otherwise
you could say well it worked well for my
8-bit multiplier
that should be good enough i'll just
trust it for my 128-bit multiplier
thank you any other questions
if not paul thank you very much for a
fantastic
talk i think ross has a question do you
have a question for us
i have a question yeah oh go ahead moshe
well you describe here reasoning about
this let's call in the tableau product
but the
people people usually implement much
more sophisticated and more economical
multipliers
so the real and the correctness there
you know the real challenge to me is not
to prove like the community of tableau
which is a nice walmart but
the re honest-to-god the challenges
prove that the sophisticated multiplier
was this recursive partitioning
and maybe it was with with all kinds of
tricks to reduce the number of beats
is equivalent to the tableau multiplier
sure so actually so they're they're
actually two
so on the hardware side that's true
um on the software side that's not what
you're trying to do
so so you don't care what multiplier
you're doing
now in fact these techniques um
will so i just described array
multipliers so they so the question if
you're doing these partial
if you're computing these partial
products as soon as you have them
um you uh you know
you could do uh you know wallace trees
or whatever
there are other there are other
multipliers or other tricks where you
you know you don't use full adders you
do other things
i i totally agree with you what you want
to do is is check your multipliers in
isolation
then uh actually the polynomial calculus
approach
is is is not a bad approach there's some
there are some issues
uh there as well cutting planes in
principle can
handle all that it's just our
pseudo-boolean solvers are too weak
to convert those clauses into
constraints so if we did something like
cryptominisat
where we could take those uh linear
constraints and infer
linear constraint from clauses to do
that type of thing
then we would actually be fine with
testing those but it's a great
it is a great area and actually uh how
you combine those two
um so uh yes i think some of that
uh is uh you know that's that's uh super
important as well and
what i've shown so far doesn't address
that in principle cutting planes can do
things like that
but um we just showed a simple example
uh mina you had raised a hand did you
want to type in your question or just no
no that was my mistake i
lowered it all right ross did you have a
question
well if you have a time a kiwi question
paul a great great talk
other lessons in how to accelerate set
instances of these problems
so um right so the
in general i mean this is this is not
from
from this so in general the issues with
accelerating sentences this is related
some
earlier work i did quite a long time ago
what you're trying to avoid
is getting yourselves into sub problems
that are unsatisfiable
and uh that's that's uh uh
difficult uh and you in general
we just get intuition about trying to
make sure that the sad problems are
avoiding these
uh solvers are avoiding nasty unsat sub
problems there is a question in the chat
uh
uh super tick do you want to ask it live
quick
quick question so pathetic yeah uh
thanks paul
so uh i mean are there properties for
which
we know that i mean it's better to
use resolution than cutting planes
because
it's going to blow up badly with cutting
planes no no so in fact we know that
cutting planes is
always more efficient than uh resolution
and you only need coefficients too
at the biggest coefficient the issue is
practical implementation
yes i'm talking about for practical
solvers yeah
so it's it's a it's a factor it's not
it's it's not a it's it's a generic
uniform factor it's just you can do the
local decisions incredibly
quickly with sat solvers and there's
just more data structures to manipulate
there's no
special blow up it's just a factor works
that's all thank you thank you for the
great talk paul
and thank you everybody for the
fantastic questions